we can't ignore Julian Assange and the
charges against him I know I'm not
referring to the sexual misconduct
allegations in Sweden and I'm not asking
you to like this guy he's kind of an
[__] I don't really like the big deal
here is that the U.S is charging him as
a spy for publishing classified
documents on the internet the very
Foundation of how journalism Works
relies on journalists going out and
talking to sources and being able to
publish what those sources say and those
sources can remain anonymous and
oftentimes they're publishing classified
information and the reason we do it is
because it's in the public interest it
is newsworthy oh wait how is this
different from the charges against
Assange if he can be indicted as a spy
why not the New York Times journalist oh
because Julian Assange is a hacker he's
not a journalist guess what journalist
is not a legal status journalists don't
enjoy some upgraded version of free
speech and Free Speech keeps our
government accountable want to charge
Assange with conspiracy to hack a
computer if the evidence is there knock
yourself out but calling the publishing
of classified documents a crime is a
slippery slope that could seriously harm
journalists ability to keep us informed